I came here six years ago exactly almost
exactly six years ago as you
remember you know that Denis and Andy
that will have this seminar and the
topic back then was trying to convince
everyone to use GPUs and you know the
you probably know that David Kirk and I
wrote that the GPU programming textbook
and you know so at that point we we were
at the point where just quite a few
speed supercomputers started to use GPUs
and I was one of the co you principal
investigators for the blue others
machine and right before I came to
Stanford for the for the seminar I went
to MSL for a review and I was hammered
by the review panel and they say that
nobody will ever use GPUs for computing
and so today I don't think I need to
make that argument anymore so I'm not
gonna give that seminar
okay so I'm gonna you know talk about a
few things that we learned building
practical AI systems and applications
and how we're developing the machine
that we believe will be the right kind
of machine for computational
intelligence or some people call AI but
I prefer to call call this computational
intelligence so that this work is done
in the IBN illinois Satori's our Center
which is started in 2016 you can just
you know use that link to go to the
center and then it's really set up to
create game-changing AI technology and
systems as any said so eloquently you
know AI will be pervasive when it
becomes really cheap very reliable and
you know very accountable right so so
there's several dimensions that were
innovating and I'm gonna walk you
through this because a lot of these
things that we experience let you some
of the design decisions that we're
making you know for the erudite system
the a our applications were focusing on
you know the video analytics and
document analytics and so you know we'll
talk I'll show you a couple examples and
AI tasks live our libraries Stanford has
been extremely successful with the
natural language
processing your primitives and you know
so that is one of the you know big
contributions to the natural language
world and we believe that you will need
to have the next level of what we call
the task libraries that you know what
further you know push that to stay up
the art and then you know we need to
build platforms and tools and before we
build any system I always believe that
we need to make sure that we know how to
measure the system and we know how to
improve use the measurement to improve
these systems so I'm going to show you a
male-model scope which is the primary
tool that we're using to evaluate all
the AI pipelines that were you know
we're building today and then the hard
work you know how do we create low-cost
storage class memory near memory
acceleration the technology is not quite
there yet but there are some really
promising ones and we're prototyping
with the flash technology today and
they're part of the conversation that I
had today with sabasha group is you know
exactly where we're going to be able to
find the mass-producible low-cost
storage memory you know the base
technology and then near memory
acceleration the center is funded at
more than 20 million dollars for five
years and that we have you know 14
faculty members and 40 grad students but
more importantly we actually have over
15 abeyance staffs who are spending a
lot of time working with us and helping
us building prototypes and so on in my
opinion that's the most valuable part of
this you know the center we I personally
learned a whole lot that I'll show you a
couple of the you know what I mean by
prototyping and so on okay so these are
the core faculty member and faculty team
and so Gingin is my co-director and if
you look at you know that the list of
faculties we really span all the way
from computer vision to natural language
processing to data mining all all the
way down to you know hardware you know
the synthesis even so though these are
the you know so this is
the team and it turned out to be
extremely valuable when we you know the
build and evaluate the systems
applications and so far we have
published 56 help papers out of the
center and this is actually something
that you know the academically you know
we have not been able to produce you
know there are so many major
publications out of most of our centers
and so this also tells us how exciting
the field is because you know that there
are so many innovations going on and
some of the papers are in the system
category boulderr2 and then our nips you
know the which is the machine a I
general and machine learning and ACL is
that and so on that's the natural
language processing and then the
computer vision conferences and
computational creativity comprises ICCC
is the computational creativity and so
you know I'm not going to be able to
walk through you know nearly I'll
probably focus on only about you know
six of these paper kind of topic you
know through the talk but you know that
all these papers are available on the
website so when we design a machine
there's one very important thing that I
learned over the years but there's never
proposed a machine without knowing what
the machine is supposed to be doing so
the you know for any student who want to
design new machines the first thing I
said is you know to show me the
application that you really want to be
able to support so the in this Center
you know we we have been looking at
applications extremely carefully so I
assume that many of you know about the
Watson jeopardy challenge right in 2011
you know the Watson you know the
computer you know defeated the check
Jenkins who was the defending champion
for jeopardy right and so this was the
pipeline that they use you know in that
contest and if you look at the cut that
that that software pipeline you know we
start on the left-hand side and we have
this you know input essentially question
and the topic analysis Ibn actually
cheated a little bit in that competition
because they didn't use verbal you know
the voice you know the input they
actually use the you know the the
special jeopardy interface for you know
for for people who cannot hear and so
there is a text
you know input and interaction interface
to accommodate disabilities for the
contestants so I being used I interface
so there's no voice processing no speech
processing and but even the text that
come in they have to do quite a bit of
what I call the estimation and
constraint optimization and a word
embedding and you know today in today's
world we will be using actual neural net
but during that particular time they did
not use neural net for that particular
you know the contest and the principal
component analysis so these are the
things that you need to do in order to
get a reasonably accurate you know the
interpretation of that what that
question is asking and many of you
probably experienced this you know when
you use something like Amazon echo or
you know something like you know Google
home and if you you know if you say
things in a kind of a more
conversational way these you know these
devices often can get very confused
because they don't have deeper analysis
about what the question is about they
don't have these kind of you know the
analysis to actually try to figure out
what the question really is or what the
command really is they're just looking
for some keywords so this is you know
one of the things that we experience a
lot you know if you look at you know a
lot of these applications even though
they're doing well reasonably well today
but in order for them to improve to the
next level the difficulty and challenge
can be really really high and then you
need to have a huge amount of data you
know if you only want to use that
approach you know to get that accuracy
and then once you have the question
their topic analysis there are actually
multiple ways you can interpret that
question so all these different
interpretations will lead to different
paths
so that's those are the past that we're
listing in the bottom and for each
interpretation you're going to use the
interpretation of the question to search
for the answers
and this search will involve grass
research matching index search and
content based search so it depends on
the kind of information that you have
you'll have these different modalities
of search and once you have you know
some of the candidate answers they also
have a you know the the evidence you
know that pass which is you know the
down you know they're kind of in the
middle of that picture here and this is
to validate your proposed answer with
some of these evidence and these
evidence may not directly contribute to
the suta to the answer but they provide
you know some kind of you know the
correlation or some kind of you know
corroboration about you know how these
answers could be true and then you know
you you you use that to give a
indication of how strong or how weak
these evidence are for the for the
source for the answer and eventually you
take all these different paths and you
do a constraint optimization to minimize
cost risk and maximize the accuracy and
then you get an answer all these things
need to be done in less than three
seconds and that's the Jeopardy you know
that latency that is typically a
contestant will be able to hit that
button within three seconds so if the
computer takes more than three seconds
in you know chances are that you know
the other side will win so that this was
the hard constraint that they had to you
know that to deal with so they have a
lot of these machine you know the
machine learning models in the final
consideration for the gut as you know to
run the constraint optimization and back
then they used the models like SVM
models and kick in years neighbor kind
of things but today if you look at a
similar pipeline in the watson you know
the structure today many of them are
neuron that days now and so you know
that's kind of a you know the the the
pipeline structure that we're seeing
again
and again in you know in some of these
you know I always say you know
sophisticated air applications so you
know in 2017 we worked with IBM to
produce a application which
automatically generates sports
highlights and analytics and then so
this is mostly a neural net based
approach with you know some of the
rankings based on the constraint
optimization you know the solutions and
so you know the in 2017
you know the IBM deployed the system for
f1 boudin and generate that the ranked
you know highlights so essentially for
every tennis game you would detect the
highlights were the excitement through
the emotions and through that all the
sound that you know the refers to the
audio and the video to determine that
the beginning point and end point of
exciting place and so that you know that
sometimes you you know you have to use
both in order to be able to get accurate
results because you know the you there
may be a lot of plotting and so on but
you may be after the play right there so
there you know quite a bit of these kind
of you know data we actually had to use
a lot of data to be able to you know to
get a good detection of that and so one
of the more recent applications that we
you know we built in the center is a
automatic conference reviewer assignment
system so in our in my field you know I
have been the program chair for quite a
few conferences and one of the very very
hard problem to solve is that the
program committee members are heavily
overloaded so you know the it is you
know we all know that you know two days
before the deadline for these reviews
you see that every you know every half
an hour were so the program committee
member will enter another review they
say okay you know that's how much time
the first person was using for you know
the review in the paper but then so
started a few years ago most
this program committee started use
external reviewers right and they wanted
to you know to spread out the work and
involve more experts so that they can
get better quality reviews and so one of
the challenges is that you know you want
now you have you know hundreds of the
reviewers potential reviewers that you
need to assign to these papers and you
know whatnot share some of the program
committees you know I have a very small
the subcommittee to do this kind of
assignment but we always wanted to be
able to have a you know a more
systematic tool to be able to do this
Toronto built a tool you know a couple
years ago the problem with that system
is that the potential reviewers need to
go and enter the you know entered the
keywords of the the topic so we said
okay that's not very usable you know
though it's already hard to get people
to agree to you know to do review so
what we ended up doing was we actually
go when and ingest it that all the
previous papers from iske HP CA and
micro so worth a few thousand papers and
in the past you know 20 years 30 years
or so and then you know so we use the
abstract and also the author list of
those papers and did a topic analysis so
this is one of the you know that the
data mining you know techniques we use
the LSA you know to generate that the
traffic vectors for these papers and
then we ingest that all the submitted
papers you know the abstracts and the
authors then which we generate the same
you know the topic vectors and then we
use these to you know we we match up the
topics with the neural nets and then we
did a conflict of interest matching and
this actually turned out to be really
really problematic because the author
names are not the most reliable way to
disambiguate people so the author names
often times gets spelled differently and
then they may belong in different
institutions so even use the institution
to try to you
to descend agree that this had a
challenging so we had to build several
AI tasks you know to be able to do the
desegregation and so on so that I kind
of come back to that point later and
then eventually we run a big constraint
optimization problem the so we need to
have minimal number of reviewers per
paper when you have no more than a
certain number of papers assigned to
each reviewer we need to you know make
sure that the program committee members
you know are you know the there's
certain number of program committee
members assign to the review and then we
need to have the the reviewer ratings
you know some of the conference's even
have some previous even ratings you know
by the fellow reviewers about the
reviewer performance of this so we we
put that all into this constraint solver
and then we give a proposed you know
assignment and for iske this year the
program committee accepted about 80
percent more than 80 percent of our
proposed as you know the you know review
and then they say that you know this
particular these suggestions were as
good or even better than what they would
have come up with because you know
there's certain things that they you
know they say you know they didn't even
realize that someone some of these
people are particularly you know
interested or expert in a particular
topic I'm not going to go into this this
one but you know I'm going to you know
go right into that task libraries so I
already hinted this in order to build
these good AR applications one of the
most important factor is how many of
these past libraries are available if
you have really really high quality test
libraries you will be able to build
novel reliable air applications if you
lack those then everyone will be
starting from scratch and we all know
that you know the units the software
industry did not thrive because everyone
started from scratch
you know they're all these api's today
that there are critical for our existing
software systems so the the task
libraries that we ended up building in
the center
or you know mostly focus in you know in
three areas one is the image video
analytics and so we we built object
detection traction and classification
you know libraries and we built a text
grounding libraries and these are the
libraries that take the videos that
generate the text description you know
for that and then the the content based
searching you know how do we you know
reliably enable the jitna that
extraction of feature vectors from that
you know from the images and to be so
that we can do video level and image
level content debate searching but for
the document understanding part you know
we we had to build temporal relations
from scratch because we couldn't find
any you know reasonable library for
doing temporal relations so when you
parse a you know a piece of text you
know which event happened before what
and you know which event happened at the
same time and so on and that's also
important in understanding the causal
relations so you know that that is also
a very hard you know the you know even
to this day I think we we finally got
some reasonable attempt at temporal
relations
you know the capability but we're still
you know struggling with some other
causal relations and named entity this
emigration topic modeling semantic
capacity some of the words have a lot
more general meaning than others so
computer science is probably a more
general word then let's say you know
operating system so so there you know
essentially you need to have a method to
create ontology and rather than relying
on your users to provide ontology
because user provided ontology never is
never going to be maintainable and so on
and then the semantics the sentiment
analysis you know the are when the paper
mentioned a particular piece of work is
the paper agreeing with that piece of
work where the paper is saying that that
piece of work is incorrect right so so
that really you know the makes a lot of
difference in terms of you know how we
make conclusions about you know
for the work and how we assign reviewers
and so on right into these systems and
computational creativity you know how do
we quantify creativity and this piece of
work actually started with Shep Watson
at IBM and so chef Watson has a feature
of you know creating what they call the
creative dishes and so they actually
have a underlying you know the database
about the molecular molecular level you
know the contents of each ingredient and
then they use that to create that you
know to predict the surprise or the kind
of the new newness of flavor that the
you know the the the person was eating
the food will be able to you know to
experience so we started with that and
then you know the started to formalize
some of these things and last loved
Varshney who used to be at IBM in that
what chef Watson team is not on the
faculty Illinois and he's now extending
that into other aspects such as the
writing such as the solution you know so
the engineering solution or the even you
know some of the you know the less
obvious solutions to some problems so
the fourth object detection and tracking
this is actually a fairly common you
know AI task there are many quite a few
you know the code available and that the
models available but you know still can
be challenging when you have different
lighting conditions occlusions
and you know grouping and then fast
motion so so these are the kind of
things that you know we started to
understand that sometimes you cannot
just use one model you know that if you
really want to have very very reliable
you know the tracking of these things
sometimes you need to have multiple
models so so this is this begin to go to
lead into some of the you know the work
that we're doing at the infrastructure
level to be able to enable the fast
switching and the fast connection to
different models under different
conditions and that we one the number
one place in the 2017 a media city
challenge you know using with this task
you know this piece of library and that
person parsing how do we you know you
know systematically decompose the human
you know into different parts because
this is foundational to gesture you know
understanding and you know the
predicting of motion and so on and so so
this you know that this particular
library also has some real challenges
especially you know when you have you
know occlusion and multiple people
involved and it's very very easy to for
these things to be confused so we won
the number one place in 2018 cvpr
and we for the three tracks single
person multiple person and fine-grained
a multi-person you know challenges graph
you know so graph is one of those things
that you know the traditional NLP use a
lot and the traditional NLP parsing
would build graph structures out of the
sentences and paragraphs and so on and
the it turns out that you know for
serious processing of unit of documents
and so on we still need to use graphs so
that we you know so we were built we
built several graph analytics you know
libraries and we participated in the
DARPA hype HPCC you know eighteen
challenge for triangle counting and
trusty composition with the GPU and FPGA
library so now you know with these
applications and libraries which we
started to see that there's some you
know serious you know I would say
challenges running these applications
cheaply right then using n DS term on
the existing machines and but before we
you know the we go out and you know make
some of these you know the decisions we
we've built a first build a couple tools
and like platforms in order to be a for
us to be able to you know to actually
observe and improve you know some of the
things and then
you know the guide our hardware design
so the first piece of tool we built was
a male model scope and this is a tool
that allow us to be able to you know to
to measure the effect of machine
learning models on application
applications so this this is a open
source framework so you can find it
online and then it's it's hardware and
framework agnostic so meaning that it
supports multiple of the frameworks and
models is that it doesn't depend on
particular hardware either and is
extensible and customizable so you know
we can we can also measure that you know
that if the performance of these machine
learning models on in real applications
so you allows the user to specify you
know how the hardware and software
stacks are provisioned and then
abstractions of the frameworks and
profiling frameworks we we actually call
there's quite a few profiling frameworks
from different vendors in order to give
us the view that we need and then for
the output we you know we can define the
data consumption schemes so that we can
make reasonable you know comparisons so
this is a example that is mostly the
architecture for the the Sports
highlight you know video generation and
these things are actually pretty 8 it
mostly what distributed saw software
infrastructure and a lot a lot of these
functionalities are invoked with REST
API and you know so you know so you we
and also most of these are created with
the you know the component with the
container technology so on the left hand
side I'm showing that the source code
with the user functions and these user
functions will invoke either their own
models or they will go to the model
category and say for IBM for example
there's a machine learning as a service
you know the IBM cloud so you can go
through a life
log and say I want to have the seeing
understanding API okay I wonder you
built that API and that gets you know at
the wrong time that I guess you know
translate it into a a container with the
software a binary and then the you know
that when you execute the container it's
going to be either invoke the function
or it's going to go through the REST API
and invoke some of the server's you know
that this is you know to be able to you
know invoke the the the cloud service
API and so in order for us to you know
to understand the performance
implications of the T of these neural
net models we need to be able to take a
full latency of the entire process okay
so from the users point of view from
beginning to end when the request is
made and until that the answer comes out
you know what are the components of the
you know of the latency so so this is
the capability of the system but I
wanted to show you you know that what
some of the typical usage of this kind
of tool so this is a you know a real
case that we use when we went ot and
media both at GPU came out you know we
wanted to understand you know how the
different frameworks are using that both
a GPU okay so so here we show a four of
the frameworks tensor RT MX net cafe 2
and cafe and you know it's very
interesting that these you know these
frameworks end up with very very
different performance for for the Alex
the net performed model so you know some
of the NARC you know much faster than
the others and then but with a male
model scope what you can do is you can
open up the convolution layer for
example you can open up each section and
see how that expands into the GPU
execution details how does that break
down into the data copying cost how does
that break down into the kernel
execution cost and tensor RT some of the
tensor RT you know the library cost so
so the you know the I'm
showing you at the bottom you know all
these different components and what are
the library functions and you can even
tell if you know a particular framework
is using the NVIDIA library or is using
its homegrown library how in fact it is
homegrown library is and so on with with
this kind of measurement so in practice
you know it's actually very interesting
that you know if you look at the the
generations of hardware for example
people would imagine that the voltage
GPU being you know that much faster in
terms of computation and even somewhat
faster in memory bandwidth the vote that
you know the GPUs should be faster than
the Pascal GPUs but there's one factor
the important factor that is you know
x86 does not have MB link between the
host and the GPU whereas the IBM you
know the power machines have MV link
between the G CPU and the GPU so even
though the IBM power machine a power
eight machine use Pascal GPU which is a
little slower generation but because of
the MV link the overall inference is
actually faster lower let total latency
compared to an x86 machine using a vota
then this is because you know that you
the the fully connected layer is the
layer with the most weight right the
convolution layers have much fewer ways
than the fully connected layers so so
that's why you know in this particular
inference the fully connected layer is
much more important than the rest and so
you ended up with less performance so
this particular you know the tool is not
one of the three recommended harnesses
for ml perp so you can actually go and
get the tool and then you use that for
your own studies quite a few people are
using that for you know that you know
scrutinizing their models so one of the
interesting things we learn about
latency you know Andy mentioned this
latency and you know latency is one of
those things that are you know really
really hard to get rid of so you know so
here is
a you know we we run a set of experiment
with all the you know quite a few models
on the left-hand side and then the
different you know different frameworks
MX net cafe and the cafe to and and
tensorflow
on the horizontal side with and without
GPUs so you know the these then we you
know we measured the total latency so
these are that you know and then we
assign the percentage portion of latency
to each cause the make the three main
cause of latency are the model loading
how you you know you when when the
inference request comes in that you need
to load up the model weights okay into
the into your GPU and then you have the
input you know the processing these are
the scaling you know the scale of image
sizes and you know some of the
pre-processing you're generating that
the right vector you know into the
models and then the the compute part
which is the you know the neural net
itself and so you know right away you
see that a lot of the frameworks a lot
of the frameworks the latency is
actually dominated by model loading it's
not dominated by the neural net you know
evaluation so if you try to use the GPUs
and you know the special hardware to
accelerate the neural net evaluation
you're not going to get much benefit out
of that so this is the kind of
visibility that we you know we we really
wanted to have for all the applications
so that that we can make the right kind
of hardware you know decisions so
immediately out of this picture we
decided to build a new you know model
serving infrastructure called shrimps
and so this model serving infrastructure
persists the model weights the popular
model weights in the inside the at the
main memory so when the new application
comes in this infrastructure you know
what it uses the GPU that Amelia could
IPC capability to just attach the weight
to the new application
so that you don't need to load anything
and is it it has a a couple milliseconds
of latency that it does not have you
know that is wasteful faster than you
know loading that model from the storage
and so that's and so on so this cussed
out but most of the latency so that if
you if you look through the you know the
models and you know frameworks and on
different machines you see that you know
that the latency actually gets
dramatically improved and after using
this kind of you know the model serving
infrastructure now the neural net
evaluation is the primary source of
latency and that's where the real a
salvation will start to pay off right so
so this is the reason why you know we
you know once we have the software set
up about right then we start to look at
a few things that we want to build in
the hardware so so this is really the
beginning of you know that the erudite
you know sort up that the design
rationale for erudite so if I look at a
hardware for Watson jeopardy 2011 this
was the description that you can
actually go back to the 2012 article and
then you see you know this is what I
being listed they have 90 servers and
you know 500 gigabyte per second on ship
bandwidth and then you know 15 terabytes
of memory and 20 terabytes of disk
clustered and so on and so it can
deliver up to 80 teraflops if we compare
that with what we currently have 80
teraflops is piece of cake today okay
it's you know each both a GPU gives you
14 you know terabytes of single
precision right so you know that that
for neural net as you know so you six of
those you know they take care of that
you know five six of those take care of
the problem and so you know that we can
easily get that kind of computer you
know throughput however the amount of
memory that that that they needed to
have
you know the the bandwidth that they
have you know in that machine is still a
lot more than what we currently have so
when we design the paradigm machine we
wanted to specifically address you know
several challenges one is you know how
do we provide storage class memory we
want to be able to have these important
models and important you know vectors
you know remember we're not for
effective inference we're not just using
model weights you know remember those
evidence ok those evidence kind of
things and you know the answer you know
those are you know all vectors that need
to be accessed with very low latency
right so pre-loaded into these you know
machines so the storage class memory
though we would like to have somewhere
around 10 terabyte of memory capacity so
that we can essentially have you know a
for a erudite for a you know the
Jeopardy kind of contest we would like
to be able to have a college-level
knowledge ok and the skill set so that
you know they can answer these questions
as a college graduate ok so so that's
the flash of a flat flash work that
there's coming out of S Plus in the in
April and we want to be able to persist
these you know data objects so that they
can have near zero latency in it in the
data
recall so that we can eliminate file
system and language level
deserialization latency and so basically
you know we have been rewriting some of
the file system interfaces and
programming language interfaces so that
we can you know easily connect these
persistent objects into the application
rather than going through the
serialization process and that's
actually question such significant work
and that was the trim project that's
coming out of one of the ML system
conferences and the network acceleration
you know that we we for training you
know we have an inception work that does
the you know compression and
decompression in the network interface
so that we can speed up the training
process and then fournier in memory
aceleration
we just published a memory channel
network and then we are starting to do
the deep store work and I'm going to
actually show you a little bit of you
know how that works
and then the for communication a
collaborative execution we need to have
a way to characterize for any given
system we need to have a very accurate
characterization of all the
communication paths and this is actually
one thing that we don't teach very well
you can't be the architecture in modern
you know the computers they're actually
you know very large number of paths in
the communication paths for data
movement so you know the and the
software drivers is so on you some of
the past not necessary to other paths so
we need to be able to you know to
accurately detect which path is being
used by which driver and so on so that
we can have a reliable way of managing
that data movement okay so that's our
comm scope
you know infrastructure so let's start
with the you know the flat flash by the
way if you have question you know feel
free to ask right the way I'll repeat
the question I realize that we're being
recorded so I will repeat the question
if you ask me up before the end and so
how do we you know to provide a storage
class memory today when I'd look around
and you'll say you know if I need to
build a 10 terabyte you know main memory
system today what would be a reasonable
cost you know technology I can use so
that it doesn't break the bank you know
even though we have you know twenty
million dollars of funding most of the
funding is for grad student support and
so on right so we're not you know it's
burning all the money building one
prototype machine so we ended up taking
the SSD that you know the flash
technology today if you have a large SSD
drive in your system you can you know
produce kind of a large memory machine
by memory mapping okay through that and
and and that you know the you know
interface the problem is even if you
Matt you did an nmap you will still have
page faults okay yeah when you access
the data that is you know the that's
still in the SSD you still need to use
the page fault to be able to bring that
data into your main memory and that
caused two important problems one is
cost software costs overhead of course
we all know that write a page
translation and so on so that's one but
that the more subtle thing is when you
have a lot of page faults the page
faults are handled sequentially they're
serialized so there's not a lot of
parallelism when you try to bring data
into the you know into the memory and
that's I actually in real systems that's
actually a very very significant problem
so what we did first is that we change
the host bridge and we so that we
enabled a direct access pass into the
SSD so that you know that the CPU
doesn't have to go through the page
fault and CPU can access either the SSD
or the DRAM so that you know if the data
is not reused often we just let the CPU
grab that data directly from SSD and
that also allows us to reduce what we
call the the data magnification problem
because if you always have to bring
these pages into the theorem you know if
you are using only a small portion of
each page in your access such as the
graph applications you would magnify the
amount of data you need to transfer
right so so that solves that problem but
then you know there are certain things
that will be used often for example when
we are using the weight that model
weighs they tend to be accessed quite a
bit you know so we want to be able to
just you know that moving into the RAM
and also through the caching system so
that's why you know we we have a
promotion process and that requires
Hardware change yes
so question this one you access cash
directly yes so you know the let me I
need to clarify this so when you need
say access cash directly yes okay so
when you access the SSD directly so that
the data actually comes back into the
cat into the CPU cache it doesn't come
so it comes back in the cache
granularity yes sit again okay so what's
the penalty of accessing the cache line
size versus the page size so this is
this goes into the implementation so SSD
if you look at the the SSD devices
they're still fundamentally a page you
know that infrastructure so what we did
was we took away that the flash
translation layer and use the GPU to do
the translation we still do that the
we're leveling but we do it through the
the CPU you know virtual memory so we we
actually have it you know change the
Linux to be able to support this so now
we free up the deer and in the flash
translation layer so if you truly have
only one you know that one cache line
used in a whole page the cost is that we
still transfer the entire page into the
flash translation layer DRAM it just
that it doesn't go through the PCIe and
it doesn't pollute it the theorems
the system DRM system but still yes it
does have that
Lake total latency so if you use the
entire page that's great right because
once that's in the T in that ssed Ram
then you can you can just pump them out
very very quickly yeah so this is a this
not goes to the driver side either
actually that you go through the memory
I owe you know of the PCIe so it is
transferred as a PCIe packet okay
yes exactly
yeah so that's the current generation
and we actually have a second generation
using the open SSD interface and that
open SSD interface allows us to do
things you know with lower granularity
and also more parallelism
exactly for the photo flash exactly so
that's the reason why you know the when
I was talking to the spaciest group that
today you know there's certain things I
learned about that you know that work
and I really feel that fact you know
eventually that will be a very
interesting path right for the RN
technology so today you know you're
right
you know there the granularity cannot go
too much lower in you know into that if
if you're always going to only touch one
you know
cache line you still have penalty it's
better than what you're experiencing
today with me and map but it's still
going to be slow okay it's maybe two
three times better so so that you know
the this is the architecture you know
that we we have a promotion lookaside
buffer that we prototype with a fpga and
then you know we we did the you know the
so that the SSD cache management and the
promotion manager in the SSD cpu and so
for graph computation you know that so
this is the you know the PageRank and
kinetic component analysis for the you
know the for for the graph and analytics
and you know so if we look that the
speed-up that we have here is you know
basically the speed-up over the
traditional software stack and as the
the number of the amount of SSD
relative the drm size grows our benefit
gets girls okay so so this is you know
the what this is the the reason is you
know as the SSD size grows and you
essentially you begin to you know to
trash the DRAM as you you know if you
always bring the data into that DRAM
so that's the capacity so the you know
the we were not pretty confident that we
can build a reasonably large you know
that somewhere around you know one to
ten terabytes of memory with reasonable
cost in a single you know you know
single machine however you know
bandwidth at some point becomes you know
the important because you don't want to
build a ten terabyte machine with very
very limited bandwidth which is sixteen
gigabyte you know access or 32 gigabyte
access through the PCIe right so there
needs to be some you know better
treatment so you know let me walk
through a few slides to you know to make
sure that we're on the same page so you
know here is a very simple simplified
view of the IBM power and nine newest
system with NB about a medium voltage
east GPUs is structured as a to socket
CPU you know the machine and each socket
connects to two of the voltage GPUs and
so I'm looking at one of the you know
one of the socket okay so the the CPU
host you know can process the data add
about one teraflops and then it has 80
gigabytes of you know the MV link
connection to each of the GPUs and you
know as we saw in one of the previous
slides you know this is the reason why
the IBM power8 machine with Pascal GPU
can actually outperform an x86 machine
with a Volta is some of these you know
inferences because of the the data
transfer bandwidth now for a typical x86
machine that is about sixteen gigabyte
per second today that is the PCIe 3 ok
generation
so the for the then the GPUs you know
the two GPUs also connect to each other
with a gigabyte per second and the GPUs
have HP m2 and which has 900 gigabyte
per second bandwidth and this is very
very important for this GPU performance
if you know using that that hpm
successfully is critical for a lot of
the training and inference applications
so if you ever run out of your memory in
HP M which is 16 gear by which is also
capacity wise its 16 gigabyte okay then
you will need to be able to get your
data from the DDR memory which is on the
other side of the CPU through the 80
gigabyte per second you know memory
interconnect MV link or if you further
run out of you know space in the system
DDR in the power a machines a half a
terabyte okay if the machines that we
have is half terabyte if you need to
have one or two or does the so on
terabyte you need to go to the SSD the
SSD is about 10 terabytes and that
access bandwidth is 16 kilobyte per
second so let's do a little bit of an
exercise let's say in the best case we
use our HP m2 which is you know 16
gigabyte capacity and that the access
bandwidth this nine hundred gigabyte per
second sounds great on but you know if
we want to be able to achieve peak vota
compute the throughput which is fourteen
single-precision teraflops we will need
to every operand that we fetch from the
HP m into the GPU we need to reuse that
data sixty two point three times to be
able to you know to to sustain the
compute otherwise we will be limited by
that that HP and bandwidth and so or if
we don't have data reuse that's the
other extreme if we cannot reuse the
data at all every time we need to just
you know will fetch one data we process
it we can
we use it then we can only achieve less
than 1.6 percent of that peak and we do
have quite a few applications that have
that problem in fact we measure these
things all the time and we see quite a
few of those so let me give you one
example for iterative constraint you
know sparse matrix solver of you know we
actually don't have more than two times
a day that we use so it's kind of you
know in between but it's very close to
the non-reusable part and this one
essentially you know we would be
sustaining about 100 gigaflops rather
than the 1.4 teraflop you know peak okay
so it's for this particular application
you know we're looking at right around
you know less than us you know I would
say 7% or so okay of the you know of the
you know the the peak so you know once
if we need to access data from the host
memory which is actually very very
common for most of our real applications
today we actually need to pull a lot of
the data from the host even a trips
server actually you know has a lot of
data in the host memory and we pour into
the GPU on the basis because a lot of
the bigger you know the models are
almost used up the entire GPUs we cannot
afford to put all the data in the GPU
memory and other weights in the GPU
memory just attach we actually need to
pull quite a bit of that from the CPU
memory and that's going through the 80
gigabyte per second and whenever you put
anything across that interface you
better use the operand 700 times so that
the GPUs can you know they can get get
to the peak or if you don't reuse the
data you will fall down to 0.14 percent
so in many ways you know people would
tell you if you have very large data
applications if this is the dilemma of
GPU computing today if you have very
very large data processing that's where
you you could really benefit from a high
compute throughput device but
then you suffer from that that data
movement bandwidth limitation so GPUs
are actually over designed computing
device for many many applications today
okay and you know so this is something
that we all know but you know it's
actually very you know I would say when
you hit you when you look at some of the
application performance data and I say
oh yeah I know that but it still hurts
right so you know so if we run a
iterative solver you know from the CPU
memory and just pull the data from the
CPU memory into the GPU through a
unified memory interface we can sustain
no more than 10 you know gigaflops and
ten gigaflops is actually a very slow
embedded CPU today okay so this is how
you know how that the sort of that
system balance is not quite right in
many applications today and then if you
need to you know pull the data from the
flash then you need to reuse the data
3,500 times and we are sustaining less
than one gigaflops and you said okay
these are interesting things and what do
you see in practice so you know triangle
counting you know code when we you know
participated in a DARPA challenge you
know I'm not going to go through all the
calculation with you but you know I
listed all the steps so that you can
actually go through it so basically we
get a at that application level we get a
throughput of edges process per second
okay and so you know the so if we take
that number and go through the
calculation of you know roughly how many
edges are there for each you know the
triangle counting means that you take
each edge and then you'd see if there
are two other edges that you know that
connect from these two points and they
overlap right and that gives you a
triangle so if you can't do the whole
thing you will realize that you know we
are actually processing about you know
thirteen point six you know the gigabyte
per second to the edge list elements
okay and that you know the
essentially it tells us that we're
limited by the memory bandwidth with
nowhere close to what the GPU is capable
of doing in that you know in the
computer throughput so that's these as
to you know a practical method we need
to have a practical method for the GPU
or CPU to tell the meant that the
processing units in the memory near the
memory interface so that we can have you
know the compute to be not limited by
the memory channels right we need to
have the computer on the other side of
the memory channel and there's another
problem that we need to solve which is
how do we give you not bandwidth out of
the SSD side so but that's not what's
being solved in this particular work
this work is just how can we enable the
CPU and GPU to tell those will compute
to do the work turns out that you know
there is actually a very real problem
that you know if the software needs to
be rewritten you're still not gonna be
enough traction for this new hardware so
we you know in collaboration with IBM
we built a memory channel Network
essentially we make all these devices
look like Ethernet devices in the system
so that the CPU or GPU can just
communicate with them as if they are
separate you know computers and the fact
that they're in the same box you know I
actually on the same board even it
allows us to drastically reduce the
overhead of Internet Protocol so that
basically that you know it would no
longer transferring data where that you
know sometimes we can just that the data
is in the host but it also is in the
device because the device is part of the
memory space right and so we can play
these kind of tricks to drastically
reduce the communication protocol and
data movement overhead you know for
getting these devices to do the work but
it's transparent because you can use
spark to so we actually run spark on top
of this you know this network and it
works so so that's the you know that's a
existing approach and we we have you
know
more you know much more you know that
would say aggressive approaches but this
is the baseline that we're going to use
for you know processing the you know the
processing that the graphs and so on and
you know in the first generation and
this is prototype so we actually with
the help for IBM we prototype the MCN on
the come tutto board which is puffer dim
so the IBS servers use buffer team to
allow them to have much bigger may
memory than the you know the sort of the
commodity servers and then the buffered
import called come tutto also has enough
fpga space on it so we actually
implemented the protocols on the
embedded processor on that board and the
you know some of the processing in the
fpga so that you know we we prototype
that board and do the demo of the
functionality so you know the
communication over here is so much lower
that even if you you use a very small
weak you know embedded processor on that
computer board we can still get
significant been you know speed-up over
using a separate server across the
network you know in the in a cluster
environment so that this shows that we
have about two times performance in you
know advantage over those kind of you
know servers so moving forward you know
so let's kind of just you know
conceptualize these things a little bit
you know I'm showing you quite a few
pieces but I wanted to come back and
then put you know put things back and
say you know these are the things that
we're trying to accomplish number one we
want to remove the filesystem front
access path to very large data right we
want we don't want to see filesystem
anymore and even that the application
wants to see the filesystem we're going
to implement the file system in such a
way that they just directly connect to
the you know to the persistent object so
we get rid of the storage and then we
put the storage into the memory system
and that gives about 10 terabytes of
storage and so that we have two benefits
one is no more filesystem overhead as
serialization
civilization over hat and the other one
is now we can access the data more about
a hundred gigabyte per second rather
than 16 gigabyte per second right so
that's the first step and you know
there's a series of papers that let you
that note that the capability and then
we want to be able to put about 100
gigaflops you know computing capability
into the you know into the memory
culture
channels so that we can actually have
compute throughput that is proportional
to the data capacity and then bypass the
memory channel limitation so this was
the actually micro 2017 and we currently
were prototyping this particular use
case for that computer this is called
deep store and it's a in storage
acceleration for intelligent image
search and so conceptually image search
is fairly simple okay you have an
offline phase that process all the
images that you have your system and
then you index them somehow you generate
some kind of vector so that you can do
the search and then you have the online
phase which is underneath when a new
image comes in you calculate the
features and the vectors so that you do
the search and this is actually how you
know the Google and then Facebook and
you know that the Instagram is doing the
you know sort of the you know that the
fast image search in software today and
then so we prototype this by calculating
the the feature of you know vectors it
turns out that each image actually has
multiple features because depending on
the search depending on the applications
they actually need to have different
kinds of feature vectors so this goes
back to you know not my previous comment
that the you know the not a single model
or a single way of generating vectors
will be able to satisfy many
applications the different applications
were even different scenarios of the
same application may require different
you know vectors and different model
weights so then you know so what
the applications come in with to the
query and then you know we we do the
search so you know so this is one of the
the cases that we prototyped with the
fpga board you know on a memory channel
so we do a you know essentially this is
a person you know the a person that may
be in different angles and then you know
you you go and search for the same
person in the system you know the in
different positions so the what we
stored in the system is a side view and
then you know the and then we have a
back view of the person then we're
trying to identify whether that person
is there and this is very common in you
know video surveillance basically you
have multiple traffic video videos and
so on you're trying to see if you can
find that same person right in your you
know in your stored videos so that
that's actually how some of the the
movie you know some of these movies
things are about you know how they find
the same person in different traffic
videos you know this is the kind of
things that they're supposed to be using
so so this you know then that that the
two vectors go into the fairly shallow
neural net to be able to find you know
the similarity and so on so so that's
you know what we hope to demonstrate
with that prototype and so that we can
publish the initial usage result of the
of the near memory acceleration
capability of erudite so in summary you
know the we have you know the erudite is
a project that is driven by high
potential area applications we feel that
you know we now we have you know good
understanding of some of the other
applications where skills try to
understand more about the you know these
other high valued area applications and
it's supported by instrumentation
analysis tools you know we you know it
took us a long time to build some of
these tools but once we have these tools
with we know what's going on and we can
we can properly identify you know the
real opportunities and the good old
endures law you know still you know
endures law and then good though you
know the percentage of time and so on
they all they're all still true ok it
doesn't mean that when AI
becomes you know popular all those old
laws code out of the window they are
still there they're well they're they're
well they're healthy and they're going
to they're going to come right smack at
you you know if you ignore them right
and then design this design with modern
software interfaces in mind so you know
we're you know we specifically design
our tools the environments to be able to
handle the most modern you know cloud
software deployment infrastructures and
so on that we can dealing with reality
we remove the salt the file system
bottlenecks and the serialization
bottlenecks from the access path to
large data sets and then we increase the
memory parallelism in accessing large
data sets this is actually one of the in
my opinion the most critical
breakthrough that computer architecture
really needs to have in the next couple
of years our ability to access large
data set with high bandwidth is very
much lacking okay and the only way
practical way is to spread the data into
multiple nodes in a you know you may
serve you know data center cluster
however that in yourself incurs the cost
of data moving to start with right and
placing compute into the appropriate
levels of the memory system hierarchy we
we are pretty confident that we can
build machines where the acceleration
happens on the other end of the memory
channel however there are opportunities
if we can tap into the you know the the
hierarchical organization of the
non-volatile memory you know because
these memories are all consist of banks
and you know the different you know the
chips and so on they're actually a very
large
number of entities inside the each
memory Channel and currently were not
tapping effectively into the parallelism
and but that way requires some
significant change even to the SSD you
know then there's the ability to expose
these things so we have been working
with two of the vendors trying to you
know to get that interface
you know available to us so that we can
you know begin to you know to show
benefit and then the data access
bandwidth proto is proportional to the
data capacity and this is something that
you know we see in in the history again
and again that the server's you know who
that violate this principle actually you
know that don't get used very often so
that this is that the primary you know
weakness of most of the large data
servers today and collaborative near
memory of celebration with CPU and GPUs
how easy it is for a CPU to say you know
let's process all these things and then
give me the answers what will send me
the data into my cache or for the GPUs
to say well you know rather than
fetching that into you know into my my
chip I want you to do some
pre-processing and then only for the
data into my unship second level cache
so we currently include that there's no
way to do this today okay but you know
we are prototyping you know that with
immediate a driver that will allow us to
be able to do this which for those of
you who are familiar with GPU
programming on the inside the GPU there
is a mechanism called a dynamic
parallelism and that you can launch
kernel within that GPU kernel so we want
to be able to extend that capability to
launch kernel into the memory right
so so that is you know the part of you
know what we're trying to do beyond the
memory channel network memory channel
network is the ability to run a spark
application you know without change
right in inside these you know memory
processing devices so we're hoping you
know with all these you know the things
added together
we're already beginning to see you know
somewhere around you know that not quite
a hundred times the improvement yet but
but we're beginning to see somewhere
around twenty to thirty times the
improvement but with the right kind of
interfaces you know in the future we
were shooting for greater than a hundred
times the improvement with that you know
we hope to be able to have robust high
efficiency you know the efficacy
cognitive computing applications we want
to make sure that you know people are
not will not just try to use one neural
network together to get some answers
they should feel free to run multiple
neural networks and use constraint
solvers to be able to minimize the cost
in any way they feel you know that they
see fit
so that they can get much more robust
solutions and I think you know that
would be critical for self-driving cars
for you know good you know that you know
personal assistance for good robotics
and you know many other things so with
that thank you for your attention and
you know if I'd love to have any more
questions okay
[Applause]